[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
what are our top 10 memories of 2018 and
given that we have not shared these with
each other but corollary question is and
how many of them overlap what if there's
a 100% overlap that way I would say a
lot about is 100% sure that there will
have a 100 percent overlap what because
you've looked at my yet oh no you
haven't look at my list have you if our
list matches 100%
I will eat both of our lists and your
jean jacket right now I will eat the
whole thing and this isn't this is a
loved one sitting and you heard of here
now there's a teaser plus our wives and
kids will probably be upset that like
well considering all of our top moments
had to do it just to each other because
yeah that ain't going a good percentage
of mine are just personal so if those
were your favorite memories then we've
got something to talk about and yeah
mind skew personal - I think that's
healthy I think that is healthy
well let's decide at the end but it is
appropriate that we're having this
conversation now because this is the
last ear biscuit of 2018 and that's when
the the top lists happen you know that's
just what happens if you if we did this
in January for the first time ever we
talked about it just waiting to do it
for a January episode but I was like man
so that's the future we know that we're
future forward so see how many of these
I think you've heard some tidbits of
some of these stories but uh yeah in
moments but maybe not so this is the
last episode of 2018 light link said and
just a quick reminder so the first
episode will be on January 7th that's
when the next the 2020 season starts
January 7th but also starting in 2019
all the video ear biscuits will be on
their own YouTube channel youtube.com
slash ear biscuits it's not just gonna
be the new ones but it's going to be all
the old ones
the whole catalog of ones that we have
video for and then the ones that we
don't have video for we're gonna just
put them out there as audio with a
picture right yep just so you can keep
we have them all in the same repository
so you can go over there right now and
subscribe to that YouTube channel
youtube.com slash ear biscuits if you
want to watch us talk as opposed to just
listen to us talk the audio will still
come out roughly a week before the video
version yes in the new year so that's
how things are gonna work so I have my
list you have not cheated and looked at
my list you're just folded up so I could
try to read that I couldn't I could you
can't read that far no I can but I did
really strive to really squint don't do
it
so glasses that's another thing that
might happen in 20 nights you know Oh
already you're ending problem I already
got problems so what I suggest we do is
that we alternate presenting our tenth
and then go down I think we're already
thing the same thing and then and then
maybe they'll one on my list will be one
of yours that higher ranking on your
list you can go ahead and mention it at
that time right
if reference go ahead and mention yours
get it out of the way but you know what
I want to go ahead and skip to one in an
effort to just make a shameless plug
good of ours I would like to go ahead
and spoil or skip to mine um half of my
number seven okay okay so half of my
number seven you got two parters there's
that there's a couple of two parters I
might have a two-parter
one of the top my seventh top moment of
2018 happened in November when it was
our last tour of mythicality show we
were on the stage performing it and I
remember you know at the beginning we
each have we each have like a monologue
that we say and like the likes up on me
and is down on you and then the light
comes up on you and I'm standing there
and I get to hear you talk about the
start of our friendship like when we
first met our first impressions of each
other and I remember making a conscious
decision this is the last one we're
onstage in front of one of the largest
crowds we've ever done this show - in
fact
the largest crowd no it was one of them
it was the largest crowd it was Foxwoods
like four thousand and I just made up my
mind I'm gonna savor this moment that's
the last show we do and that was it
that's a that's a mental picture I have
when I'm just I'm looking just like I'm
looking at you now I'm looking across
the stage you're doing the last
rendition of this show that we worked so
hard on and that we took to Australia
and then we took around the u.s. before
that and then we did a couple more spots
than that wrapped it up so that was a
that was a big moment yes in our career
just kind of coalescing something that
we will never do again that you can
never see if you didn't get a ticket I'm
sorry
there's no way to see it oh this is a
good setup the tour of mythicality stage
show where we encapsulated lots of our
book of mythicality
in stage and dramatic form or you could
never see it is there a way to see it
yes there is a way to see it because
when we did the show in Los Angeles at
The Wiltern we actually filmed it yes
so we have produced our own special the
tour of mythicality special that you can
go and get you can pre-order right now
on iTunes and you don't just get the
special you also get a documentary that
we created that documented our travels
while we were on the road and also kind
of some of our perspective about the
tour and that kind of thing yeah if you
remember our Instagram stories from the
tour fall of 2017 you would see in a lot
of those that one of us was also holding
a camera because we documented some of
those stuff ourselves and then we had
some help and documented some things so
it's a lot of prep a lot of creative
hand wringing behind the scenes stuff
and I think you'll really enjoy the
documentary just as much as the show
itself maybe yeah so you can pre-order
that on iTunes but so again that's the
tour and the tour documentary together
on iTunes however you can also on iTunes
or wherever music is available right
most places
you can get the tour album the live
album so all the songs that we performed
live and a studio version of the song
that we close every single show with
best friends till the end song we
recorded a studio version of that in
this room right here we recorded that
because this is also our recording
studio so you can get that album as well
is that album available for pre-order as
the album just good to go now and so ok
so you order all of it
yeah just buy it blindly basically is
what pre-order is all about just buy it
based on trust just trust us yeah just
try the great exercise
speaking of exercise I'm glad that we
did this exercise you know there's a
little bit of homework involved it
actually a lot I don't know how you went
about this did you just sit in a
meditative state and reflect well I sat
down and I was like I started to think
and then I was like I have a horrible we
actually are known for having a good
memory in terms of like being able to
access things from our childhood like
for the book and that kind of thing but
that was because those are stories that
we've told multiple times yeah we
accessed but when I think about just my
past year I was like what am I gonna do
and then I was like oh photos on my
camera exactly what I did - I think
that's what most rational people would
choose to do and I was glad that and
then I was like well what things did I
experience that I didn't take photos for
and yet I was able to then I would
looked at our calendar then I looked at
the calendar yeah and then the third
thing I looked at was tattoos of all the
things that we did that you have on your
back that you're going to reveal right
now no my my digital journal or my
note-taking digital space I wouldn't
really call it a journal but I do
journals some thoughts that I have there
and there's dates associated and that
that jogged a few memories so they can
get to that those three things three
things put it together and then I I I
did it by month just so I would have a
list and that became a journal entry now
that I want to do every year which is
like a by ma at the end of the year a by
month highlight and then I was like I'm
not gonna rank these because I don't
want to show favoritism to any of
moments from our life I just want to be
able
enjoy each moment as if it were the best
and then I told you that right before he
did this and you said that's a bad idea
you should rank these yeah nobody wants
that ranked top ten list that's not
ranked yeah you gotta crank it this 2018
is a pretty good that's a pretty good
point 2018 for just a little bit longer
so I have ranked my list um and I I did
and it was not easy to rank and also I
think I can tell by looking at yours
over that that you had some honorable
mentions I also had some honorable
mentions that I was like I think these
may these got shifted off as I as I
sifted through the memories yeah yeah so
we'll skip those and then maybe
something that happened to me was in
your honorable mention or vice versa
so do you wanna go ahead and start start
with number 10 yeah before we we go into
our ad break start with your number 10
so the least special moment of 2018
amongst the most special moments of 2018
though you was one charitable way to put
it was when we went around town with our
good friend Mike Edwards to find the
best pastor taco in Los Angeles that is
something that we documented on the
rhett and Link Instagram and it was one
of those things where Mike said he was
talked about it a little bit but Mike
said he was coming into town he said we
got to go back to that place to get
tacos yeah and then I was like well what
if we just went all around the whole
town and found the best ones documented
the whole thing
do you member when this was what month
this was cuz I need to add this to my
list it was it was to my digital journal
it was pretty early it was January or
February oh it was yeah it was pretty
early in the year and the thing that
first of all I find that and I've talked
about this a little bit I really like
creating experiences like that's one of
the that's one of the reasons that we do
the game night isn't just because I'm
selfishly want to play games and
experience those people but I really
like it creating an experience you like
being a ringmaster and then like being
like all right let's just do this thing
all
together and see what happens well and I
think that the it makes part of the
experience
adding a little bit of structure that's
why I always like a competition that's
why if you're all gonna get together
somebody made win something you know I
liked it because we weren't competing
but there was a competition that's the
sweet spot for me yeah we were like and
then Mike was really cool and gracious
to actually be excited about the fact
that was on our Instagram versus guys
I'm coming into town I see you a couple
of times a year you guys gonna Instagram
this whole thing he loved it he was
really he likes to eat quite a bit so
that you know you just take a taco in
his mouth and he'll be happy about
anything
he wasn't unhappy about the Instagram no
he wasn't he was oh yeah that was the
number ten that was a good moment I
totally forgotten about cuz yeah I
didn't know how Instagram you don't go
on this I didn't I didn't look did you
look at Instagram photos because I
didn't look there uh I just had a bunch
of I had all the videos that we created
that night you did Laura my photo album
oh okay is that how it works I think if
you save them you can save them to your
I don't know how it works but yeah I saw
it on there maybe I just saw pictures
I'm held my number ten doesn't involve
you sorry okay doesn't involve our
friend Mike it doesn't involve tacos or
this doesn't involve anybody but you
anybody with me that's right
in September I don't think I told I
might have mentioned this to you but I
don't think I've told anybody else I
decided you know like looking out from a
house I can see a mountain in the
distance hmm I might have mentioned this
on here but my time ago up there and I'd
been up there once and it was I actually
I didn't go I didn't make it all the way
for time constraints not for like
physical constraints because I'm a
specimen no I I made up my mind you know
what that was over a year ago I'm gonna
do that again I'm gonna get up at the
butt crack of dawn and I'm so I can get
back at a reasonable time and not spoil
my whole Saturday be a little family man
too and I I took a hike all the way up
to that mountain top and it
like a six-hour hike and I had this I
had this playlist this like instrumental
playlist that I put on my earbuds right
at the beginning and it it turned out
like I listened to it the whole way up
and the whole way down and it the way
that the playlist timed out to end as I
was ending my hike it was like a magical
experience like a magical moment of are
you referencing the time and completion
like walking no I even took a wrong turn
and had to had to backtrack like a 1/4
of a mile almost and it was still in and
that was fate saying I want this Spotify
reflection playlist to end it just the
right time and so and it was it was it
was the most grueling hike I've ever
done and like I don't know since that
time I went to Yosemite just out of
college really yeah which says about me
to hike very steep well it's very long
there's more about me but it was an
exercise in solitude that honestly
replaced on my list me going to Slab
City which is another exercise in
solitude which others honourably mention
and I because I knew I'd already talked
to you guys and maybe that all about it
maybe that kind of push it off my list
cuz I didn't want to share it which is
not a good way to make a list for me I'm
making it for you you can't think about
that but they're similar things but the
reason why I ranked this one a little
bit higher was because it's much more
accessible for me to do again and
something that's like it engenders a
higher likelihood of an exercise in
solitude just like a half day hike
versus like a two day trip it's I could
I feel like I can go out there and do
that again you know so that's why it was
it was a bigger moment especially with
the playlist no yank you could do it
even more often if
every time I take a hike and I get to
the top of the mountain yeah I'm like
man I wish there was a zipline you know
what I'm saying you get up there and
you're like I gotta go back down the
same dadgum trail it's gonna hurt my
knees my middle school why didn't they
put a zip line we would be constructing
a zip line now what do we think it would
cost and how much pushback would we get
from like this the county if we hire any
if we like put a zip line in just
without asking from the peak of that
mountain behind your house to your house
to my house all the way to the bed that
that would that would generate a lot of
hiker traffic at my house with everyone
coming I don't want to zip line to
terminate at my house mm-hmm
yeah good point well I mean there was a
project about your neighbors have
proposed to put a not a zip line but uh
one of those ski trolley things is big
friggin to do one of those too and from
the Hollywood side and it's it's still
being considered in some circles a
gondola a gondola it's different
okay that's my number 10 okay well we've
got a lot more to go and we're gonna get
to that in just a second but first we
want to let you know that we've got
headwear oh yeah headwear and mythical
dot store link is putting on the head
where right now this is my Mike hands
off first these are these are new
options this is a we call that tan kind
of like what do you say is that a six
panel what do you call that it's five
dad hat unstructured London structured
dad hat and because that's what the kids
are ironically anything better if you're
not a dad yeah if you don't like it on
me you'll love it on yourself if you
like it on me you also like it on
yourself yeah it's a mythical logo
featuring the Rambler has a leather
leather strap yeah pointing at your hand
oh the inside well that's cool oh that
look it says some about my hand
it says mythical all along the inside
look at that leather strap
and if that's not warm enough for you we
have a beanie bring it back to beanies
this one's black which says mythical
super mythical this is great for robbing
homes it doesn't have I hold it's not
it's not a robber mask it's just a it's
a beanie dude no it looks like what
Pesci had on in home alone he didn't
cover his face because he was Pesci you
know I'm saying but no he but he he had
it exactly the way you had it before
back up on top that's the Pesci look
rolled but his didn't say mythical you
don't have to oh when you unroll it it
also says mythical both ways you can't
get away from it you can't get away from
drowning all this anyway mythical dog
snoring notes on our merch we're just
trying to sell it mythical dot store
headwear galore a little bit more a
little bit more just throw it on the
ground cares about it's just a hat
alright let's get into your number nine
I believe we're at and you know what we
should probably do well let's just keep
going back and forth for now okay yeah
because they okay so mine my suspicion
just even just based on your first one
is that you're gonna be a little bit
more of a specific this is the time this
is the time I was looking at you it is
the kind of thing am I just wait my
brain works it's gonna be a little bit
more general but then I have some
specificity within the generality I'll
accept it so number nine for me is the
fact that I kind of discovered skiing
with my family yes as a thing that was
in January right at the top of the year
yes so we went to Big Bear our families
went together and then I ended up going
back again with my boys one time after
that and then I ended up going with my
family to Mammoth which was like next
level in terms of the amount of
seeing that there is available and is
amount of snow and just the quality of
it and and now we're planning a trip
that's what we're gonna do for their
Spring Breakers we're going skiing but I
really like it as a as a sport it's a
little it's I feel like there's danger
involved and I really and I could run
into a tree at any point but I don't
really go that fast I can also just fall
at any point these don't run into a tree
I don't go that fast I take it pretty
easy I don't go into crazy places I
don't go I don't leave this course or
whatever they call it the trail but I
enjoy a lot personally but I enjoy doing
that kind of thing with my boys a bunch
Jessie nuts she's not so much into it
she did it and she learned how to ski
basically and then she's totally fine
with us going as a family to do it over
spring break but she's like I'm gonna
read a lot
she's a larger yeah she's a larger and
but there was a specific moment so she
dislodged comes from basically we need
to dislodge when you get your white out
of the lodge you dislodge her the the
specific memory that sticks in my mind
is so shepard would go to these lessons
because you can kind of put the younger
kids into these all-day lessons which is
a great way to just forget about your
kid and also get them to actually learn
how to ski without biting their heads
off personally because you don't know
anything about skiing in my case yeah
but he would get out of skiing and then
we would be able to ski just a little
bit before everything closed down for
the day and there was just a moment
where me and lock and shepard were all
kind of skiing well trying to get down
the mountain shepard was falling
repeatedly because the lesson was
apparently not very effective but at
least in the moment where we were all on
our feet and we were all going down the
slopes i was like this is what i thought
being a dad would be you know you have
those moments where you're like all
doing something super awesome on a
mountain and you're like this is being a
dad finally yeah and then your son falls
and slides down the mountain and leaves
his skis way up high and you have to
somehow get back up this slow
and then like a stranger starts to help
him and then you're like I don't know
how I feel about that but I do
appreciate you helping and then you're
like I don't like being a dad
that's now you're in it that's the
balance yeah that was an honorable
mention for me and my kids learning to
ski at the January thing but we didn't
follow it we haven't we haven't been
back since I got a I got to do that you
go right on your lizard didn't got just
got to ski again number nine for me I
won't spend much time on this because
it's very fresh and we talked I talked
about it very recently but I have
reflected on it even more and it has
increased in magnitude since it happened
and we even talked about it on here and
that is at Thanksgiving when my mom and
Lois were at my dad's side of the family
for Thanksgiving that's a moment that
well I didn't put it in these specific
terms but this is what I began to
appreciate it was the first time that my
mom and dad had been in an event besides
I guess my high school graduation that I
can remember since I was like 2 years
old so in my memory you know between
high school and then college graduation
and when we would have babies and they
would both show up it was not it was the
first time that there was like an
elective we don't have to get together
but we did and that that's it's gotten
even more of a big thing in my mind so
again I thought about it recently so not
today
not to realize my number 9 but they did
get together at the barbecue dinner that
we did for mythicality they kind of that
was but it was a one that was a in order
to experience the event they both had to
be there it's just like the birth of a
child it was less intimate it wasn't it
wasn't really elective like they oh it's
elective elective it was the first
elective thing that they both showed up
at you saying they could have chosen not
to come
yeah just like every other year when we
have things give me separate right
yeah big moment number eight for me is
my solo trip did make my list okay
I talked again I talked about this
relatively extensively on the podcast
earlier this year most notably talking
about the experience I had in the yoga
dome oh I thought you tell me when you
spent 20 minutes in the bathroom know
that like every other day every other
day this is when I went to Avila Beach
and we say to that weird place where the
hot tub yeah and you just lay they
funnel the sulfur water into your room
or your deck or whatever I wonder if
that got affected by the fires no it's
not I mean it wasn't in any of the it
wasn't in either of the places where
there it was in between yeah it's like
Central Coast okay yeah what if you had
to make it a moment do you have one this
specific moment was so you've got like
the hot tub that is on the deck in your
room but then you've got the hillside
hot tubs mm-hmm that are on a hillside
and they're basically sort of privatized
a little bit so you can see down the
mountain but from the path that the
other people access hot tubs and they
can't see you so negativity yeah man
negativity okay nakedness let's go and
negativity I didn't see any titties I
just want to say I do I do I do want to
say that was a cuss of word because
because it's like a high I just want to
say that mine were out my route okay
hydrate I didn't see any it just said
when I started talking about being naked
on a hot tub and then I accidentally put
the word Diddy say it again run to
negativity
I'm witness I combined the word
nakedness in Nativity which there's an
idea for Christmas
oh sorry daddy good naked TV you could
really piss off a small southern town I
bet I can bind those two things that's
the thing do you uh do you want my
number oh but no but I was saying I
didn't even get to my moment it was it
was it was being I thought we told I
thought that was quite a moment it was
being naked in the hot tub
on the side of a mountain and kind of
looking out oh wow
okay sorry about that my number eight in
April was when my cousin Britain who
I've talked about came out here for the
first time he was on the voice he was
just starting to compete and they put
they hold him up in that hotel and he
couldn't leave and of course it wasn't
the first time I've met him but that was
the first it felt like it because I was
like okay you're out here doing this
thing I think we met him passing a few
times but in April that was the first
time that we met a minim at the Denny's
for lunch and I was talking to him about
being on the voice and you know was
there early on he ended up almost
winning the whole thing but it began a
friendship in a relationship to where
you know then every week after the voice
Christie and the kids we'd all pile in
the car and we drive 20 minutes in order
to meet him for dinner and whoever would
be in town that had was watching him on
the voice like his mom or his dad or his
friends or things like that we'd all eat
dinner together and like then it would
be on television at the place where we
were eating dinner at the hotel cuz he
wasn't allowed to leave right and um so
it's really cool like watching the voice
with him just after he had been on it
and it was the start of something that
now at this point starting in January
he's coming to live with us mhm
because pretty soon I ended up saying
encouraging him hey if you want to make
it in as an artist as a musician you
know you've got this album that Alicia
Keys has helped you produce and it's
about to come out
you got to capitalize on this you don't
need an fir'd north
Carolina you need to be in Nashville or
Los Angeles sir so live with us and make
this thing happen so that's what's gonna
happen in in January we're all super
excited I mean the kids are getting like
an older brother basically even though
he's about to turn he'll turn 19 right
before he moves in with us and the
living arrangers is gonna be a little
interesting because we don't have a
guest room but we have a dog house I
I'll save that story for later but I say
we're not gonna put him in the dog house
but I mean our our personal lives are
going to drastically change because
there's another it's like we're adopting
a young adult to live with us who's an
aspiring musician and um it all started
that April so I'll go back to that
moment little did any of us know when we
were eating I don't know what you eat at
Denny's a super slam no that's that's
wrestling Grand Slam great yeah anyway
and that was that's my number that's my
number seven as I've stated before
Britain is one of my favorite people now
that I've got to know him potentially
the best thing that's ever come out of
our friendship is Britain so for you I
look looking forward to him being here
you might if I could take a wizz real
quick are you serious I typically time
that a little bit better
are you is that why your eyes are
floating yeah get out of here
I mean I'm gonna keep going through my
eyes are floating I've been putting my
drops in man trying to keep my talking
self conscious it's a vain tries to keep
my eye oh oh you say it's a euphemism
for having to Pete yeah Pete I got some
peat moss I got some peat moss I need to
get out now here's the option you can
continue all I'm not or you can you can
pause it some of you I'm a positive I
felt like maybe I should go too just
because we like to sync it up you know
okay all right how you feeling man
you're back you didn't miss anything
I just took I just took my jacket off I
didn't miss anything but I did piss
anything oh gosh okay so what's your
number
what's your number seven I gave away
half of my number seven already with the
tour of mythicality
closer night number seven is the day
that me and you over the summer went
surfing and then went in ate at that
restaurant oh yeah what's the name of
that restaurant glad
Gladstone's that sounds right off the
one and I was wearing a winter coat I
don't recall that you made fun of me
because I had a winter coat in my car
and that I was wearing it and it was
summer but during that time during the
summer in general we were kind of more
in like a brainstorming phase so we were
we were coming up with ideas for
different things that some that we're
working on now some that we decided
weren't good enough to work on but you
and this is something we talked about
relatively often about finding like
unstructured creative time yeah and it
was one of those times where we got to
do something that we really enjoy doing
which is surfing and then making the
decision to just walk into first of all
that restaurant is really interesting
because and I think it's significantly
different now I don't know I think
Wolfgang Puck is like buying it or
something I don't know when that's
happening but for it to become something
else like two years from now that but
like people were kind of like dressed up
like they were going to a restaurant but
we were like in bathing suits of course
you were in a bathing suit and a winter
coat which made you look like maybe you
could get away with anything in this
town and but we we were there for a long
time because we didn't unlike most of
the time it's like what would go surfing
but we got to get back because we have a
meeting or we have this thing that we
have to be
because our time is so structured to
have some unstructured time that was a
good moment and also we got really
excited about a particular idea then we
came back and discussed it with Stevie
and she pointed out why it wasn't a good
idea
no it was one of those things that like
we were excited about certain elements
of it and she was like well have you
thought about this and when we thought
about that one thing that we're like
yeah actually that is a problem and we
never solved that problem all I'll see
what kind of stalled out it's kind of
interesting that well I'll just say it
was a concept for a Christmas movie
there's no reason not to say it don't
say what it was I'm not gonna say what
it was because I still think there's a
way to solve the problem but yeah they
still make it yeah so we can summarize a
Christmas movie it'll make a Christmas
and now here we are it's the it's the
holiday season
and maybe we should pick it back up
because we're really in the mood man I
woke up in the middle of the night I was
sleeping on both my arms they were both
dead you need to be on your back for
something to do that I know I'm well I
don't sleep on my side I guess I either
sleep on my back or I sleep on both my
arms at once but I woke up and both of
my arms were asleep I would think that
if that was the end I was it was over my
body was closed failing me just like a
Monday morning to me shutting me out
and but then I looked outside and it was
you know it was the clearest has ever
been in LA and then I'm like I come into
work and I'm I'm driving into work I'm
listening to Christmas music and then I
start to fill my arms again no don't
start driving it fill your arms but I'm
like no I had a headache when I woke up
both my arms died but then I was like I
look outside and I put on the Christmas
music and then you know what it's it's
all good and I think in that light we
should we should reassess this Christmas
movie we it was the wrong time of year
right and Chris um you know you were
wearing a winter coat you were trying I
was trying my best you just you're
trying to get down that was a good
moment so for me 7a was the
last tour of mythicality show ever and
then even though it's a totally
different time a month earlier in
October I combined this as a top moment
is that the first rhett and Link concert
at the North Carolina State Fair was my
other half of my seventh top moment of
the year because just like the other one
represented something coming to a close
its represented something blossoming
which we have again we've talked about
but it was a lot of fun and you know
we're going to London in February yeah
and we're gonna we're in where to look
looking to do some other stuff going to
Nashville yeah after that we're going
and we'll see if we can go some other
places yeah i the the tour well
since most of us might that's my top
stuff most of the tour for the tour
mythicality took place in 2017 obviously
I'm gonna talk a little bit about the
trip the big vacation that we had which
included the tour I'll just preview that
one moment so the Australia Fiji trip is
higher up on my list of course but your
time at the NC State will you tell me
the NC State concert you know I'm
talking about the tour in general okay
and I kind of mum I loved the State Fair
into the tour I know it's different I
know why it's different I agree with
that but that didn't yank my different
made it a moment for me for me I was so
I was sick that that trip and I was like
fighting off like my voice going out and
I was I didn't feel prepared I wanted us
to have more time to like go through the
songs and practice and I and I didn't
have all the lyrics down I didn't have
all the chords down that was it was it
was seminal it was important but it
didn't it wasn't a favorite memory of
mine because he was stressed out in the
midst of it so I couldn't really enjoy
it the way it was semi seminal in the
way that I hope to enjoy it semi seminal
tittie okay
I didn't think we had to say titty again
there I said it again up but there was a
moment when we were on tour since it
since you've already shared your tour
part when we were in Australia and you
know I also the the most sort of it's
that moment where you're talking and the
lights on you where I'm kind of I'm in
this I'm in the dark so it's similar
it's the time we have to like process
things yeah it's the only time you have
to process anything in the midst of the
show the show and you've already done a
little bit of you know there's a little
bit of stuff that's happening we like
sing a little song and then you're kind
of getting the vibe of the crowd and you
can kind of see people in the first few
rows and I just remember thinking we're
in Australia man like this stuff that
we're doing has connected with another
continent in a way that has gotten
people to show up to see it and I just
remember thinking that that was it was
very special so that that that's the the
Torah portion of one of my top memories
which is the trip which I'm not gonna
reveal in number yet because it's higher
up so are you going with number six now
going number six number six number six
is breakfast with my boys which is
something that I started to do weekly in
2018 okay there's it isn't happening
right now for reasons I'll explain in a
second but I was like I'm gonna take
them because I don't take them to school
because I'm gone I am at the gym or here
before it's time to take them school and
every once in a while I'll do it if
there's some but it's not a regular part
of my schedule as I want there to be
some regular thing that we do that like
mean something again it's just like
you're trying to create those Dada
moments you know you're trying to create
those coming out of Mountain moments and
I was like I'm gonna take them to
breakfast every Tuesday morning okay
what day it was and we did that for half
of the year we did it for half of the
year
we had to stop because once locks
basketball started which for some reason
started in the summer he has practice
really early in the morning and then
it's like a hour and a half difference
from when Shepard needs to be up and so
but as soon as basketball season is over
and February we're gonna start again and
then go through the year until he can't
do it again
but it's again you kind of want it to be
this thing where you're like you have
this thing as a dad I have this right
yeah you have this mindset where you're
like I'm gonna take my kids to this
diner and we're going to have breakfast
it's gonna be like a Norman Rockwell
painting I'm gonna talk to them about
their day and I'm gonna give them some
fatherly wisdom and write etc etc and
all too often it's sort of just like
you're sitting across from a 10 year old
and a teenager and they're kind of just
like it's the early in the morning and
they're just eating and you're just like
so what do you guys what's happening
today and I oh no yeah you know it's
like and I realized that those are dad
moments as well but the idea of light
whoa well let me say something that's
gonna change your day it's like not that
I didn't do that on some degree and I
hope that the memory will loom larger in
their minds as they get older but and it
did make my list
yeah and cuz it was very special and it
is special it will be again I think it
yeah I totally really relate to that I
think as I look through a lot of the
photos and all the stuff we did as as a
family or even things Christine I did it
some well especially with the kids
it's one of those what I realized it's
about creating an event or creating I
hate using this term but it's like oh
you know what I'm about to creating
space although it goes a tittie again
like we got you know I I think this is a
very I don't know if it's just in our
friend group but there's a lot of
creating
bass phraseology but it it's perfect for
this cuz it's like you don't know
exactly what's gonna fill the space but
you've you set parameters it like this
is who I'm with for this amount of time
I'm with my kids every Tuesday morning
for breakfast and then within that space
things can happen because some so much
of the meaningful things that happen
aren't what you plant it what it's what
happens within the context of that space
so it's and with parenting specifically
it's the reacting to a moment like that
moment when something goes wrong in one
of your kids lives and you've got to
respond to it or something goes right
and you're there to respond to it you
know and to experience it or help them
unpack it so I think it's I totally
relate to it that it's it's important
that you create this space that then
things can happen and then a lot of
times they nothing happens and you need
to have faith that like we have this
moment where when something does happen
I'll be here for it or this is a space
where we can talk about it and it won't
just it won't just go away you know yeah
and I'm sure that that those moments
will happen and have happened you know
yeah
within the context of breath yeah it's
not just about the eggs it just isn't as
curated as you want it to be right
sometimes I even find out with vacation
you know it's like I think it's with
everything I'll get to that let's say so
we're at number six my number six is in
May we were filming the chocolate human
chocolate fountain that was a memory for
me when you peed it into my mouth which
is one of the top episodes of the year
it was an exhilarating moment that
within the context of good mythical
morning was was was
one of the best best moments but I'm
making it a moment here because if you
remember right afterward that was the
last thing we shot in the studio for for
the extended 22 minute version of GMM
when you know launching back in October
2017 it went up into the summer of this
year and then it ended
you know us doing three videos a day
four at one point five including more
yeah then we went down to three plus one
and when I look back at our calendar
like I couldn't believe the weight how
much we worked and shot for the show how
much we were on camera filming like it
all day every day non-stop it it
monopolized our schedule at a point
where like I had forgotten how much like
we made I mean we made a decision that
like okay if this thing doesn't continue
like we're gonna drastically change our
schedule and how we work so that it
doesn't feel like this anymore and we've
succeeded at that I am so grateful when
I look back at the first half of our
year at the calendar that that stopped
I'm so relieved that that stopped well
and it may be okay that was an
investment that then this is my number
two moment it's your number two moment
my number two moment is ending the
extended version of a good mythical
morning yeah yeah I mean and yeah I can
move it up my list you guys you don't
have to move it I'm not gonna move it it
is six on mine it's number two on yours
but it German I can totally believe and
I'm not gonna argue with it being number
two because it was almost number one it
dress it changed Abe's like me to Jacobs
number one it's it changed the
complexion of our entire life well and
in look I know we've talked about this a
little bit and there's like there's
confusion about like what that was all
about and I think this one of the
general consensus
that sort of this sort of nonchalant fan
who hasn't really followed the details
would just assume you guys decided to
change GMM for some reason probably
because you wanted more ad revenue or
whatever and then everybody didn't
really respond to it in the way that you
would have hoped and then you decided to
stop doing it that's actually not
anywhere close to what the reality is
just to I've explained this a little bit
but I'll just say it again it never
hurts to put the truth out there
so YouTube approached us and basically
said we've got this new program where
we're giving people a bunch of resources
to make awesome stuff and we want good
mythical morning to be a part it was a
little more complicated in that they
want us to make another kind of show we
were like we can't we've got GMM and
they were like okay well what if we just
made made GMM even bigger and better and
part of the the process was you had to
have a bunch of different segments
because they're buying the ads for it
and that kind of thing and that's what
turned it into the multi segment version
of GMM now we were very very hesitant to
do it because we had something that was
a very particular way but it was a kind
of thing that the amount of resources
including people and money that would
come into our company in order to make
this happen
is something that we really couldn't say
no to and we were like surely with
putting this much into GMM so we're
gonna just like we talked about before
something's gonna happen this is gonna
shake things out this is gonna lead to
something and then when it started it
was like link said it was so much work
and it was all GMM all the time and as
you know we like to do other things
other than GMM we got other ideas like a
Christmas movie yeah and we want to get
to those things and we want to have time
for them in our old schedule of doing
one video a day did allow for us to do
other things so in the midst of it while
our company had been transformed we
ended up expanding our studio physically
we ended up expanding our staff by a lot
getting a lot of talented people in here
a lot of really incredible things happen
we change the way we do our production
we became more efficient
and then when YouTube not us decided
that they didn't want any more of it we
were both like wow that is helpful in
one sense because that is going to allow
us to go back to the old school version
the GMM which is what most people wanted
to begin with but every but we don't
regret it at all because of what it
allowed us to do and how it transformed
the way we even shoot the show now but I
will say that that moment that we found
out that it wasn't happening was this
huge just sigh of relief oh yeah yeah
and it transformed the second half of
the year and like I said without looking
back at the calendar I tend to forget
how much so it was nice to to go back
and do that but I'm again I'm saying
that the moment was peeing chocolate
into your mouth because oh yeah that was
what I was saying as well because it it
encapsulates that I mean it it was us
given the opportunity to pour ourselves
in no pun intended
into GMM and then what comes out the
other side is chocolate pee very much
beneficial to us lesson learned and all
the things that infrastructure yes all
of that stuff but it ended on a high
note
a brown liquidy high note yeah and there
were some occuring credible things
created in that in that in a stretch wow
so I I preempted your number too but
that's okay from a produce Oriole
standpoint we're getting to some really
meaningful stuff earlier because I drank
them differently on my right right okay
so what is your number five I believe
number five this is the year that I
discovered Palm Springs okay okay and I
know that sounds weird and one says
since it's just a town that is east of
here but a couple of things happened one
took a really awesome trip with my
family to Palm Springs
we went there over spring break and that
was where the weird horseback riding
story that I told
oh yeah guy who had the
and that's just a memory I saw pictures
of that was like that my kids are never
gonna forget that it was just a relaxing
weekend with a great experience as a
family on horseback but also some good
friends of ours got a place out there
and we spent some time with our close
group of friends and this is sort of
representative of what we've talked
about before but like we've made some
really good friends that good friends
are tough to find yeah you know good
friends are tough to find in Los Angeles
a place that has so many people but it
can be very difficult to carry on
friendships and also to have meaningful
friendships that aren't shallow and
aren't based on trying to leverage
something from somebody so I would say a
very large amount of the friendships in
this town are strategic and they're
about who you know so I can then do this
thing that I want to do and it mance
myself it was very cool to kind of make
friends with people who are many of them
are very successful in their own right
and have accomplished many different
things but that isn't the dynamic of our
friendship in our relationship in our
group dynamic at all it's not about who
has done what and who has how many
Instagram followers anybody has it's
like being in a group where and this is
interesting like once you kind of become
a quote public figure you do question
what people's motivations for friendship
is yeah and to have a group of friends
that that is not the case at all has
been this incredible blessing this year
and when we went to Palm Springs we were
able to basically have a time where we
were vulnerable with each other and like
basically sitting around kind of like
talking about what was happening in our
lives and that was a moment there where
just adults being vulnerable with one
another and getting into each other's
lives it's not something that happens
very often outside of certain sort of
structures and that was a that was a
highlight for me I was there for that
you were so it's a highlight for me too
I kind of forgot to put it on my list
though whoa
sorry friends yeah okay so my number my
number five is in February and then
comes back in June in February similar
to the you having your your breakfast
with your boys I we both instituted dad
days where it's like once a month
taking one kid or or more often that and
scheduling okay this is gonna be an
extended period where we plan something
I plan something just with one of my
kids and I've got many highlights from
from each dad day with Lily and Lincoln
but this particular one's the first one
I did was with Lando and we went to an
interactive hands-on Museum in Pasadena
and it's a highlight because it was the
first Dada day I believe but then
there's this thing that you climb up
inside and it's like the kids climb up
inside and then it spirals up and I
can't I can't remember if I told you
guys about this but um again it wasn't
so there's not much to it except I went
into thing with him and I was crawling
around inside of it and we were having a
good time and he was a little afraid to
go up to the top without me going with
him so here I am an adult inside of this
thing and there are a few adults in it
but it doesn't really accommodate adults
that well and so you're questioning the
whole time it'll be in here but I did it
anyway and it was just a special moment
for us that was like nothing happened
you know it wasn't like one of those
stories that then it becomes an ear
biscuit story where it's like and I got
hurt you know type of thing it was just
uh it turns out that then again that was
February in June I I had a dream about
the about that experience like I
reinstate via dream with Lando like
we were back in the thing and it was
like it was I was able to tap into like
the joy of the moment it was amazing it
was an amazing thing weird happened in
the dream it was the same thing yeah was
like a memory yeah weird it was weird
and it helped me appreciate that yeah
that was a very special moment that
again maybe at the time it's like yes
the dad day creating that space so to
speak or like going to the museum that
was good but it's like it actually came
down to that moment like my brain said
okay I'm gonna dream about this and it
was so it became even that much more
special and I held on to having recalled
their memory then now it's it it's even
stronger so much so that it represents
Dada day it represents my relationship
with Lando you know and so yeah it's
it's it's the top moment where we're
just having a good time in this confined
space that kind of smelled like stinky
kids yeah it's like it's like a yeah a
ball pit at McDonald's all right so now
when I matter no matter how much you
charge all right if you're gonna if you
let kids in there with their shoes off
forget about it yeah so now whenever I
smell stinky kids
I'm catapulted to a positive memory yeah
that's a pretty good view a positive
memory okay my number for a sniff kid
sucks oh gosh my number four is
beginning to work and continuing to work
all the thing that we can't talk about
right I didn't put that on the list
because we can't it's so frustrating but
it's hard not to put it on the list
because it's it's it's defining the
second half of this year in a lot of
ways we'll be able to talk about reading
Lee we got to talk about it soon I don't
know when but it's but let me just let
me just describe it on at a high level
we're working on something that is
pulling on our did you why are you
deciding to put a teabag in your mouth
right now and I'm in this moment at the
end of it
well that's typically not how you finish
a tea bag just I know you you
transitioning from coffee to tea but
I've already had my coffee that's just
as somebody I mean to distract you I
didn't even see me if I unlike you I
have peripheral vision yeah I couldn't
see you when I was doing it I will say
that yeah you're like an ostrich you
didn't think you were seeing we're
working on something that's pulling on
our common experience our friendship and
is kind of exploring that in a very new
and exciting way that I think is sort of
squeezing us creatively as much as we
can be squeezed so that's what I love
about it and I think that there were you
know kind of making the decision to
begin working on it and then kind of the
the collaborative process that has
ensued since we started working on it
again I it's kind of the thing that
we're working on when we're not doing
everything else that we're doing so it's
kind of spanned the second half of the
year really probably for the spring
until now and anyway very excited about
it very excited about what it means for
us creatively very excited about what
you guys are gonna think about it and to
me that's been it's been a highlight
definitely
it made my it wasn't before for me
before yeah before and if we could talk
about it it may be even higher than
number four
hopefully in retrospect it will be
successful enough that it would even
move up the right side oh because it led
to so much that's an added bonus but
even if that doesn't happen it's on the
list I think it's important that it's on
the list now but having not realized its
potential yeah or failed my number four
is a sad one it's um in May is the the
tragic unexpected death of my uncle my
dad's sister's husband my uncle Dan
the
I'll narrow down to an interesting
moment it was after so the family went
home for the funeral and then we left
the funeral and then one of the things
that he always did was he was a big
quail hunter and he had these he he bred
and trained along with my aunt TC these
all these hunting dogs and then after
the after the funeral and the that was
like a it was a meal at the church or
whatever and then she was and TC was
telling my kids about well I've got a
litter of puppies that's just been born
that then we were gonna you know it
would be the next batch of dogs and then
we were gonna train and they sell these
these dogs because of their bloodlines
and their their training how well
they're trained and so we went out to
the farm and saw the puppies and so I've
got this picture of my aunt TC with my
kids holding these like newborn puppies
in the in the wake of you know arguably
one of the saddest moments probably the
saddest moment that our family has
endured it was like such an unexpected
and terrible shock and still is in a lot
of ways especially for my you know for
my aunt and my cousins and those closest
to my uncle their dad or husband and I'm
but that much it was a very surreal
event and then that was a very surreal
moment where it was like there was just
a lit you know aunt my aunt was able to
find a little bit of joy in sharing the
super cute puppies with my kids and it
was and we took them out for the first
time she said let's take them out for
the first time into the field and we're
gonna test to see if they're gonna come
when I call them and and not just run
around everywhere scattershot and then
it's like word when we chasing puppies
and maybe losing one I was actually
nervous she seemed very confident having
known this
and so that whole event was is um you
know we loaded the puppies up in these
kennels and took him to come down and
the in her four-wheeler thingy but as
we're loading them up I look over to the
left and the tractor that my uncle was
on when he was in the accident was there
it had overturned and that's how he had
died it was they had they had basically
turned it back over and brought it up
and it was in storage there in the barn
just adjacent to where we were and like
I look over at it and it was like I was
they were getting the puppy so I was
alone over there with it and it was it
was it was a haunting moment you know to
see the the wrecked tractor and that I
was like oh my gosh she didn't tell me
that it was here and you know but what
could be it's not like they could just
get rid of it that quickly I guess that
was a very haunting moment that then we
got the puppies loaded and we took him
down there and they're running around
and they're successfully following her
and the kids they're just laughing and
it was just in the middle of this
horrible event this this you know I'm
not gonna be cheesy and try to draw some
sort of like the puppies of the
beginning of life I am in no way saying
that I'm but you're gonna I'm not really
I'm just saying that there was there's
just a moment of joy in in that that she
was able to have with my kids that like
was a little bit of relief yeah it was
also right before he left it was the
last time that I saw my papa before you
know the next time I saw him he was on
his deathbed when I flew into town so he
was at you know he was there
he was talking to people he was sitting
he was eating with everybody it was the
last time he was out and about that I
saw him before he passed away just two
months later when we so you know our
family went through a lot this year and
and I've I've shared a lot of that in
detail but you know I think that that
that's a defining moment and makes my
number four for the year but you're you
the moment you have with your Papa had
to be it but if that you told you talk I
know the way you think so the fact that
you talked about it in a podcast you
didn't put it on your list but that's
alright see on your list yeah I think
you know I decided not to put that
moment higher because III didn't want to
retaught about it honestly I think
that's really what it is but do you
think there may be a lingering question
it's like wow having no heard me talk
about why but not higher I think I know
what am i what you talked about your
tendency to not want to rehash things
but also the fact that you didn't think
you were ranking them and so you came in
here this morning right but if I had to
called you on the weekend and said I'm
ranking mine right
you would have probably that that one
would have been based on the way you
talked about it it would have been
higher yeah I mean I'm making up
separately from the moment with the
puppies I'm saying the moment you like
where you shaved your grandfather's face
and all that stuff
yeah I I don't about extensively right I
don't think that yeah I just I think
officially I will probably put that at
at my zero which is higher than number
one if I've already made a number one
well I appreciate you saying that
because I think it was just okay I don't
want to really get into it again on a in
detail on the podcast why don't you go
ahead because you took my number two
already well I've only got two more okay
so why don't you go ahead and share your
number three my number three is my
birthday and my wife's birthday together
so our 40th birthday party which again I
talked about in here the the bowling but
in going back through it first of all
I'm you know we had the big bowling
party and we hired someone to take
photos which if you've got a big party
that is meaningful to you I highly
recommend getting someone who knows how
to take photos and pay it's worth
whatever you want to pay them to get
somebody to do that in terms of like
serving those memories so I was very
happy that we did that when I look back
at it because I think the main takeaway
now having had all these months since it
was that so many of my friends were
there basically all of my friends made
it it's kind of a it's a difficult thing
to do in LA when it's like can everybody
show up and I think that was such a
defining that that's what I'm gonna call
like the moment the thing that I
appreciate looking back at it but that
was a big moment and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna sneak in another one that's part
of that because then that was in May and
then Christie took me to a nice hotel
with like a rooftop pool in downtown Los
Angeles and we spent the night there we
had a nice dinner and but we're you know
it was my birthday we were up on this
pool rooftop pool and I'm looking on
social media and seen all of these
birthday wishes from people I'm like
this is such a surreal place to be like
I have this ideal moment where Christian
are having you know sometimes just the
two of us celebrating my birthday but
then there's this added bonus of I've
got all these people tweeting at me
about how much they want me to have a
great birthday yeah and I was like wow
that is a that is a that is a grand
benefit of being YouTube famous is you
got a lot of people probably more than
like the ratio standpoint of like fans
who wish just normal celebrities a happy
birthday there's a there's more of a
sense of connection so you get a much
higher quality birthday wishes right
which I was listed at which I was
listening to some music reading my
reading my birthday compliments
sunbathing with my wife on a pool table
a rooftop pool that's a moment it
reminds me because I didn't I haven't
said anything
a lot of these moments time with my wife
is sort of implicit in them like the
family moment but there was a way I had
a significant relational moment with my
wife in Palm Springs that was like
something that we talked about in terms
of like a moment of connection and sort
of you know you when you've been married
for 17 18 years this I guess I'll be 18
in June mm-hmm
you know a lot of those like you know
each other so well so a lot of those
like really pivotal relational moments
or things that happen like when you're
getting to know each other and like
earlier in your marriage yeah and then
you kind of settle into your marriage
and the way that you carry out your
relationship and and those sort of like
taking your relationship to a new level
those kind of moments become a little
bit less more hard to define yeah I had
one of those moments this year that was
very significant that's folded into that
palm springs to dim what I didn't want
to forget about that yeah I think
there's there is a private list that it
may not be specifically shared of the
way this is our public list well yeah
yeah unless you want to give more to
details I don't want to get the details
yeah
so number three for me I went with a
very general thing but I do have some
specifics it was our trip to Australia
and Fiji so I've already talked about
the tour aspect of that but I have two
moments within that trip and I think
this says something about the way that I
see travel in which you kind of hinted
at earlier then I sort of remember being
when I felt the best about these trips
yeah
and that was the first day after we had
gotten to the hotel in Melbourne and we
were just we walked across the bridge
into the city and we're just walking
through the city we're gonna go to that
restaurant that our friends who Jaden
who's from Australia from Melbourne had
told us we should go to and you're just
like walking across this bridge and that
walking through town and like taking it
all in I'm just like this and not always
my personality is if there's something
new and it's something different I'm
registering all the ways that it's
better than
anything that I've ever experienced I
remember you specifically that's my
personality
look kids there's a Burger King yeah I
like it you were very excited it was
it's a little different is it called
something different it's called
something different yeah it was not
called Burger King yeah cuz they
couldn't call it that because there was
a guy in Australia who had a had a
burger stain called Burger King and he
wouldn't he won a lawsuit and they
changed the name of Burger King Hungry
Jack's yeah that was it but uh anyway
we're not fooled kids that's a Burger
King this is a there's a lot about my
personality that that's my number one by
the way The Hungry Jack's
hey I'm really excited about
circumstances and I want everyone around
me to enjoy it as much as me and I
started annoying people with like
pointing things out and being like isn't
this great
alright I gotta learn to keep that
inside but then it's also the very
beginning of the trip yeah because
that's inevitably what happens with me
because the other highlight for me of
the trip was something that we've talked
about on the podcast before is when we
got on that boat in Fiji and went across
the ocean at night couldn't see anything
except the Stars and we're like we got
the app out and we're like you know
looking at the stargazing app and
looking at all the stars and the planets
and stuff and it was like the craziest
clearest skies we've ever seen and then
we get to this island and there's no
dock and they just drive the boat to the
shore and we just roll our pants up and
just step into the ocean and walk onto
this island that we were gonna be
staying on and that like there's people
were singing and like yeah that again it
was the beginning of the trip now the
rest of the trip was great but it was
the moment where the expectations are
the highest and I talked about travel
expectations and how you should lower
them so you can have a great time but in
the moment I cannot get away from it and
I let it take me over and it was just
this like this was such a good choice
this was such a good idea yeah and that
was a very significant moment for me
yeah that was an amazing trip I mean the
fact that we were able to take a tour
take our tour over there
as you as you've already mentioned and
you know we just did we did those three
dates they were all very special and
then we capped it off with the Fiji
thing I mean that is my number one okay
so you have hit my number one good haha
gotcha
and it's um it's that entire trip and
it's so all of those moments are
spectacular that you've talked about and
there's so many more you know I'll just
shout out another one which is when we
were when we went on we went on the date
trip you actually weren't there the day
trip outside of Sydney and Landon was
sick we get off
we're like taking taking some pictures
this amazing overlook and land I was
like dad how do you take a selfie and
I'm like well son you just take the
phone and then you hit that button so it
turns around this way so you can see
yourself and then you just take it and
I'm giving it to him why does it and
like Lando takes his first selfie so
that's not a number one moment of the
year but it's a moment that encapsulates
the type of things that you want to
happen it's like I uttered in my son's
first selfie it's pretty overlooked in
Australia now I just it's funny that
Lando's hesitancy to take pictures let
pictures be taken of himself led to him
being eight or Wow right before it took
yeah I got selfies of like non-talking
Locke and Shepard like just like picking
peaking at the camera because he refused
to have his picture taken he wanted to
be he wanted to be a ghost now he he he
welcomes pictures being taken of him I
mean again that's another quality
another facet of that memory is that
he's he's changed and developed you know
in terms of his self-confidence that
like there's all these things wrapped up
into this goofy selfie that he took you
know where he's like he's got that funny
selfie look on his face so yeah that I
mean that that whole thing that whole
trip is my number one and it was just
man we've you know we've carved out time
and 2019 for us to have extended
vacations and we're kind of you're
marking some of that time and trying to
figure it out so I mean it actually led
to that like okay we can let's go big
well I can't carve out some time so it
no it's it create more shows you that I
mean first of all the one of the great
things about travel is because it shakes
up your normal routine it tends to be
the thing that you remember when you
look back because it broke you out of
your day to day right I even heard
someone say man this was on a podcast
I'm sorry I cannot remember who said it
but it was great advice it's someone's
dad said giving financial advice there's
only a few things you should go into
debt for but one of those should be
vacation it's like don't you can justify
going into debt for a family vacation
which yeah the eyebrows raised a little
bit right but it's like that's a
provocative thing to say it is and
that's why I said it but think the thing
that I have thought about this year is
you know when I think about what I'm
spending my money on it wasn't the only
there was a little another thing I had I
have thought that like this feels when
we're paying for a trip for pain to got
some exciting stuff I'll talk about
later because it's not happening time
soon but paying for travel in my mind is
is I'm not gonna coin a death for it but
it's justified I am like you look at the
price tag which like yeah but I'm
creating this memory so yeah I think
it's definitely justified so that's my
number one is that entire than entire
trip okay well you've already hit my
number two which was inning GMM 22 I've
not looked at your number one so I don't
know what it is but I can share my
number two yeah we can hear you're
number one okay
my number two is the RV trip we took I
mean once once we got out of our own
driveway just like which I detailed how
how dramatically difficult that was you
know we went to the Grand Canyon we did
the RV thing confined space
the dogs included it I'm so glad we did
that like I did it just because it
seemed almost a little crazy for us to
do it and okay I think you should do it
I think you should do the RV thing um I
gotta go to sleep I go try to sleep on
one but we're driving back and we're
we're like headed to those caverns that
I told you about and we're on instead of
taking the main interstate highway we
went off on route 66 and it it felt like
you know it's like stuck in stuck in
time or however you say the phrase
frozen it's frozen in time and it would
be another Disney reference but the
kicks but I mean crit the kids were
sleeping in the back of the RV and we
were driving through this like amazing
route 66 scene from cars and Kristy and
I are just kind of talking about it was
just a special moment for us just kind
of talk about how we are creating we are
experiencing life with these people that
we love so much that came out of her
loins oh gosh and it was just very cool
[Music]
laid-back moment of just driving on the
open road where you feel like you could
see for hundreds of miles either
direction in the Prairie and I just
remember that moment where nothing was
happening and it was the time of
reflection on like the tail end of our
trip that's like we did a good thing so
that that's my number two and you're
like my kids will appreciate this when
they're older hey hope you know what I'm
saying
yeah it's like yeah because you as a kid
you don't
it's very difficult to take it in and
appreciate it when you get when you when
you get older when you have kids and
life begins to move very very quickly
you're trying to create these
experiences you say the kids are only
gonna be with us for this much longer
and you're trying to create those those
memories that they'll look back and
they'll be like I did have a good
childhood my parents did love me that
when they're gonna really need it later
in life but in the moment I think
they're just kind of thinking I can get
my room yeah yeah all right so I don't
know what your number one is better be
good
well my number one is therapy is that it
yeah
now therapy for me did not start in 2018
it started very very tail end of 2017
okay I've talked about it a little bit
but the thing I mean again I'm
self-conscious anytime I talk about it
because I feel like it's one of those is
one of those really la things to talk
about and we're out here in LA in this
bubble and you can kind of forget what
it feels like to not be here yeah
but interestingly I would say that again
it's kind of very similar to what I was
talking about earlier that you know you
change so significantly so quickly when
you're growing up and you're going
through it so you think about how
quickly our children are changing as
they grow up and like we have a change
that much right you change in these
dramatic ways you know both physically
but your brain is changing and then the
way you see the world is changing and
then even in your your-your-your during
your college time and your 20s you're
experiencing these like just changes in
in in your person now even in your
personality not fundamentally
but just different aspects and I kind of
feel like in a lot of ways up until I
started kind of exploring these things
with the help of a professional that
kind of just assumed I was going to kind
of just be me
just be the same guy yeah yeah for the
rest of your life you know I'm like I'm
pretty healthy in general I mean I
originally went to therapy not because I
thought that there was something wrong
with me in my in terms of like the way
that I see myself or think about myself
I went because of the stress that what
stress was doing to me the fact that I
kind of let stress affect me to the
point that it was affecting me
physically mm-hmm and I was like I just
need somebody to help me deal like deal
with this I got help with that but I
think that the sort of the the
breakthrough for me or the beginning of
a breakthrough is when I started to
started beginning to understand why I am
the way that I am like why my
personality is the way that I am the way
that it is why I'm so independent and
why I can cry while watching a
commercial Lion King trailer like
literally King I started watching first
of all if you're not watching dogs on
Netflix I don't know what you're doing
you should watch dogs on Netflix it's a
document it's a documentary series where
they profile a different dog and human
relationship and everyone and I
literally the first episode started
crying during the opening credits and
then I just cry the whole time every
that when they're sacrificing cats like
when the opening car and speaking of
cats let me just say right now you could
not make this documentary about cats
okay hold on oh we're talking about your
therapy let's get back to you couldn't
make it
don't don't deflect into the world of
cat hate is my fault I challenge you to
make a documentary about the bond
between cats and people and all the
wonderful things these watchdogs and
then tell me that they could do the same
thing with cats
they couldn't unless your box cry let's
bring it back to you I'm in therapy for
this for my cat hatred
[Laughter]
but it's interesting because I cry
really easily at certain things like
that but then if you ask me things about
and I had a very I had a great childhood
I didn't I didn't experience like trauma
and but like if you ask me about things
that like the most difficult things that
I experienced growing up or whatever I
don't there's no I don't have I don't
experience I don't I won't cry I don't
have sadness about those things but I
can tell a story about him and make
somebody else cry but yet so I started
learning that like I you got your
emotions has to come out in some way and
so for me I had found this way to kind
of deal with them by like I'm gonna
watch this documentary about dogs but
yet not deal with what's going on inside
and kind of it's it's more is more
locked up that's just kind of the
surface level talking about it but
anyway therapy has been significant from
me because it represents sort of the
beginning of a sort of a second journey
in my life of kind of going with inside
and figuring some things out I did feel
like I'm at the very beginning of that
and there's a lot there's a lot of work
you hear people about talking about the
work that they're doing and then you
start figuring out like oh I need to be
working on myself in this way and it's
not just about some of the more obvious
things which we've we've both been doing
which is like getting our schedule in
order and making sure that we've got
things for the kids which some of that
has been really assisted by therapy but
they're like what is it about me how can
I continue to grow and then how that how
does that then affect the relationships
that I have how does that affect how
we're kind of father am and what kind of
husband I am what kind of friend I am so
that's been that's number one no
specific moment I won't talk about like
a moment in therapy in which I had like
a a breakthrough I'll keep that private
list between me and my therapist but
therapy as a whole we will be posting
our private lists on
our Instagram right he is that is that
how am I get back on it yeah sure okay
well thanks for that level of
vulnerability and you're number one yeah
and I think well there you have it it's
our it's our top ten moments of 2018
that I'm so glad that we went back
through them for our own benefit
yeah I mean at least to reflecting come
up with them you know so that we could
share know it's a good exercise to like
you start thinking like wow I actually
did some stuff this year I kind of
thought that I didn't and I'm trying to
put to get now I went through the photos
I think I'm gonna put together a book I
think I'm gonna do that this year you
can get AI to do that well now that I've
made an album that's just of moments and
now I can get the AI to take it it's not
gonna take it from like a million
pictures from 2018 it's gonna take it
from an album of a hundred pictures get
the AI to caption all the pictures with
fun fun thoughts okay
make copies from our relatives yes so
that's it that's ear biscuits for 2018
again reminder that will be back January
7th and then all the video versions of
the podcast will be over the youtube.com
slash ear biscuits brand new channel
which you could subscribe to right now
and we hope you've enjoyed this year of
ear biscuits think we changed things a
little bit as you know we're always
changing you always tweaking and the way
we tweaked ear biscuits this year was to
make it just about the two of us no we
decided to instead of focusing on bring
bringing people into interview is like
well we kind of there's two of us we can
always talk about something and let's
sort of have our friendship on display
as part of this podcast both exploring
some of our common experiences but then
exploring questions together I've
enjoyed it personally I'm enjoyed this a
whole lot more than I enjoyed when we
when we have to figure out fancy
questions to ask people that's just me
personally
well that wasn't last year that was many
years yeah yeah I know but I but we but
we've done but we still flirted with
that a little bit and then we we've kind
of experimented with what
Matt was gonna be and anyway let us know
what you think about where this is kind
of settled out we're obviously still
always tweaking and anything that you
would like to see in 2019
hashtag air best get anything you would
not like to see in 2019 if you want it
just to be mean out and we wish you
that's I mean we could do that ignoring
that we wish you happy holidays and may
your years always come to a close with
your clothes on
or actually not may your yours always
come to a close without clothes happy
new year or not to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]